can you tell the story of when you were
tortured
nearly to death in a mexican prison i
sure can and
i'm smiling but it was nothing to smile
about i can tell you
i was uh i was in a poo and a gentleman
came over and shook hands with me and
put handcuffs on me
and i thought what in the world that was
at one of the nice hotels
and they put me in a in a jail cell and
i sat there and all the trunks and the
thieves and stuff kept coming in and
they had a bucket near overrun
and i said man like 18 people in a room
about 12
12 foot square oh it was hot and i
thought
somebody's got to come get me this this
ain't real
i hadn't done anything it's like it was
a pilot coming to see me and
up in hermeseau and he stopped and he
made a mistake and went to the
international runway instead of where he
was supposed to go
and he had my phony name in his pocket
so they got me
so they said i was a drug smoker so
after about three days they put me back
into the into the back
and it was a torture place and they put
me in a little cell like i guess it
wasn't hard
it wasn't six feet must been about five
feet square and about 12 feet high
and it was june into june and it was
hot i mean hot and uh
they left me in there for i guess a few
days you didn't know
they uh so every once while they come
dragged me out
and first off they put my head under
water and it had seltzer in it or some
kind
and i took one whiff of that and three
or four of them couldn't hold me down
so then i learned it just before you
have to breathe tear loose like that and
they'll let you up
and uh that was the first treatment and
then then they started beating me
and uh they beat me blackjack rubber
hose until i was black and blue and
yellow from the bottom of my feet to my
head
what did they want from me they wanted
to sign me to sign a confession that i
was a drug smuggler
and they put the papers under you under
your nose this is all over fuel sign
well i knew if you signed
you got six years i wasn't gonna sign
i was one on the side so they didn't
want you to snitch on anybody
they don't want to say they just want me
to sign that paper and you still didn't
about to hey a beating ain't that bad
[Laughter]
so anyhow he's coming to the good part
so then
they come and they take me out and i'm
bug naked and they bend me over and they
have things to pull you like change i
click click click and they bent me over
and they
put butter on my bum and they commence
to put hot chili
pepper up there and that stuff was bad i
mean
it was red-hot and that was
that was awful
and still it was just awful yeah but
still you didn't
think about it i ain't going to i guess
if i'd known he's going to kill me i
wouldn't have done it but i'm
but i wonder about you get hurt bad
enough you'll pass out so
i didn't pass out so i was all right so
then the last thing they did was
they brought a a dead man in there and
he was wrapped he was frozen and he was
wrapped in newspaper
little strips about a half inch wide
just like a mummy
and he was frozen and he hung him on the
wall with a meat hook
and uh god you next son of a [ __ ] you
next
yeah and so he's sitting there like this
and uh
as he starts to fall out which is pretty
quick it looks like he's crying
and it looks like he's peeing and the
papers start
unraveling on him and the formaldehyde
puddles on the floor
yeah what a smell that rotten
insides and the formaldehyde and there
was a little
space it wasn't even a half inch high
under the door and i lay on that filthy
floor of my cheek
and put my lips right up under that door
and was sucking that fresh air and i
went to sleep after some time
and i know where walt disney gets it
gets his ideas
i saw white pink pigs with wings on them
all kinds of stuff flying around
so when i woke up i didn't know which
was real and which was
the nightmare it took me a minute to
figure out where i was and what was
going on
how did you stay mentally strong through
that
time like what i don't know that i did i
would
yeah i was mentally strong so i was just
like i am now stubborn
i mean you could be that man that could
have killed you yeah so could have
so what gave you hope did you have hope
yeah or you're just a stubborn son of a
[ __ ] i think some of both of you i
think
they aren't going to keep you here
forever yeah you know you're going to
get out into the prison or they're going
to let you go or something if you sign
that paper you ain't going nowhere
and i want to go home
you